as ever with this pandemic no time to
rest on our laurels with breaking news
this evening with a very worrying new
variant on our shores
yeah it's absolutely right isabel this
is a
manaus variant of the brazilian strain
of this virus manaus of course a city
in brazil we understand that three cases
of this particular variant have been
detected
on the shores of scotland these were all
identified in three passengers who
arrived into scotland on flights from
london and aberdeen their original
destination hasn't yet
been mentioned they then self-isolated
from the dis from those destinations
but they then went on to test positive
those uh
tests were then sent off to a screening
laboratory and it was there
found to be considered to be this
concerning
variant we also know that passengers on
board that flight
are said to have been contacted by um
public health officials in scotland and
told to self-isolate
all three of those people with those
cases
have finished their period of
self-isolation now after having tested
positive
we understand this is also in addition
to three
further people who have tested a
positive for this particular variant in
south
gloucestershire and we understand that
further community testing is now going
to take place
in that specific area to try and
pinpoint exactly how far it's spread